I'm Karen la talk radio's film courage
we're here at the 6th annual San Diego
indie fest with me mr. match our founder
of flasher schwarz com yes and since
starting flashers how has your giving
back to people in turn create
opportunities for yourself oh well when
i when i created this i just wanted to
be able to give a platform for aspiring
filmmakers to showcase their work and
not be you know like really doubted upon
by everyone else cuz since we're so
inundated with hearing you know and this
sucks and you need to do more with it
you know i wanted to keep them the
opportunity to have something okay i
want i want to showcase your work and
people will watch it and based on that
live over the year i've been running
this site i teamed up with craig wilson
who is warning the indie fest film
portion of it and we've done several
different events like that we created
the the sip shorts and spirit social in
LA and San Diego and I worked with him
on a few things and then I met a bunch
of other producers and since my primary
focus is a filmmaker is writing I have
been able to meet with other people and
get contacts for hopefully some upcoming
jobs plus a lot of people that I met
through flasher shorts are based out of
LA and they kind of want to get together
and meet up so I think that it's is
benefiting me for getting getting my
name out there more and kind of able to
Brandon Matt Dargo as as like
as a promoter and hopefully as a writer
and filmmaker is the Alamo that I want
to pursue but in the meantime I'm just
I'm just glad to be you know here on the
panel of you guys and do another thing
I'm doing in that regard it's it's a new
experience that I'd never actually
thought I'm never going to have and so
it's amazing and I really love doing all
of it so really giving back has
benefited me by just giving you these
new experiences that I never thought I
would ever have and so that's more
important and more meaningful to me than
even getting jobs or furthering my
career I get into all this really
complex
you